[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
ballweg
und willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick
an diesem mittwoch an meiner seite ist
für den sport norbert könig genommen und
das sind einige der wichtigsten themen
heute
omikron und die fünfte welle offiziell
steht deutschland im internationalen
vergleich noch recht gut da die
tatsächliche incidents ist aber
wahrscheinlich deutlich höher
zwangs untersuchungen in russland wer
als ausländer dort arbeiten will muss
sich jetzt aufwendigen medizinischen
pflicht tests unterziehen
und auftakt der vierschanzentournee in
oberstdorf schaffen es drei deutsche
skispringer unter die ersten zehn mit
favorit geiger verpasst aber das podest
die hochansteckende omikron variante
breitet sich rasend schnell aus nach
angaben der weltgesundheitsorganisation
gab es weltweit noch nie seit pandemie
beginnen so viele neue infektionen
innerhalb einer woche auch in europa
gehen die zahlen steil nach oben zum
beispiel in frankreich rund
208.000 neuinfektionen verkündete heute
der französische
gesundheitsminister tagesrekord gestern
auch in england mit
117.000 93 fällen und deutschland das rk
ii meldet für heute 40.000 43
neuinfektionen die tatsächlichen zahlen
allerdings dürften weit höher liegen
warum erklärt pablo seal alle
micon sorgt in vielen ländern für
rekordwerte in deutschland sind die
absoluten zahlen allerdings noch
vergleichsweise gering der anstieg ist
aber auch hier rasant ein zuwachs von 26
prozent innerhalb eines tages
verzeichnet das rk ii allerdings liegen
für diese woche hier grau unterlegt noch
keine belastbaren zahlen vor die
aktuelle inzidenz liegt offiziell bei
205,5 doch der gesundheitsminister
rechnet mit einer hohen dunkelziffer wir
arbeiten jetzt ja an der also
verfeinerung der datenlage ich habe
damit ja sofort begonnen und bin so auch
zu dieser einschätzung gekommen dass die
tatsächliche incidents derzeit zwei bis
drei mal so was wie die ausgewiesene
instanz der grund zwischen den jahren
sind viele gesundheitsämter ohnehin nur
dünn oder gar nicht besetzt hinzu kommt
ein hoher krankenstand
den gibt es auch bei den laboren der
biologe martin stürmer selbst labor
betreiber glaubt das wird sich so
schnell nicht ändern wir haben alle auch
bis über der belastungsgrenze
hingearbeitet das ist sicherlich ein
faktor den werden wir auch in den
nächsten jahren berücksichtigen müssen
und sollten das auch berücksichtigen bei
der identifizierung von omikron spielen
die labore eine wichtige rolle um die
genaue carola variante bestimmen zu
können muss die positive probe dort noch
einmal untersucht werden mit einer
sogenannten sequenzierung die bieten in
deutschland aber nicht alle labore an
seit pandemie beginn wurden in
deutschland nur etwa 44 prozent der
positiven proben sequenziert zum
vergleich in dänemark etwa waren es 42
prozent doch sind unklare daten wirklich
so dramatisch letztendlich müssen wir
einfach von dem worst case aus gehen
sprich wir haben eigentlich schon beginn
einer mikrowelle einer fünften welle und
entsprechend sollten wir agieren und das
auch kommunizieren dann ist es nicht
ganz so dramatisch wenn die zahlen jetzt
eigentlich 11 die realität widerspiegeln
die unklaren datenlage soll bis zum
siebten januar behoben sein dann findet
das nächste bund länder treffen statt
belastbare zahlen liefern weiter die
krankenhäuser zur lage auf den
intensivstationen die entspannt sich
derzeit etwas bundesweit sind
86,5 prozent der intensivbetten belegt
21 prozent davon mit kobe patienten 79
prozent mit anderen schweren
erkrankungen
13,5 prozent der betten sind noch frei
und die kliniken bereiten sich auf die
nächste welle vor etwa in saarbrücken
verena kerth
ganz langsam erholt sich seinen lungen
seit drei wochen ist alexander nikotin
hier auf der korona intensivstation im
klinikum saarbrücken täglich macht der
atemtherapie geimpft war nicht
aber jetzt
nach meiner erfahrung
ich lasse mich 100 prozent geboren ist
nikotin in kasachstan seit vielen jahren
lebt er im saarland erhard rheuma und
hatte angst dass sich die impfung nicht
mit seinen medikamenten verträgt länger
als zehn minuten sitzen schafft da noch
nicht aber allein das ist ein erfolg es
geht also wellenartig immer und es hat
ja selbst auch erlebt dann geht es einen
tag besser einen anderen tag wieder
schlechter aber moment
sehr viele patienten mit schweren
krankheitsverläufen sind nicht geimpft
eine entscheidung die sie hier
ausblenden und akzeptieren
wenn einer besoffen auto gegen die wand
fährt dann ist es mir auch grundsätzlich
als arzt erst einmal egal dass der
selber schuld ist für mich ist die
schublade eigentlich diese wir sind als
erste deutsche da die patienten zu
versorgen egal wo sie gemacht haben
34 kurve patienten werden im klinikum
saarbrücken zurzeit behandelt sieben
davon auf der intensivstation
sie hatten mit mehr gerechnet zum ende
des jahres entspannung aber heißt das
noch lange nicht für draußen ist es so
wenn die welle abklingt ist es schön bei
uns ist es so wenn es heißt die für die
welle läuft jetzt aus dann wissen wir
genau wir müssen jetzt die ganze arbeit
nachholen die man wegen der vierten
welle nicht machen konnten krebs und
schmerzpatienten verschobene routine op
es das muss jetzt schnell aufgearbeitet
werden denn für die kommenden wochen
rechnen sie wieder mit erheblich mehr
cupid erkrankten auf der intensivstation
ein ende nicht in sicht
protestierende corona verharmloser auch
in eberswalde in brandenburg waren
zuletzt vor allem sie auf die straße
gegangen jetzt haben andere an derselben
stelle ein zeichen dagegen gesetzt auf
dem marktplatz zündeten sie mehr als 300
kerzen an und erinnerte so an die korona
toten des landkreises damit sollte auch
ein platz geschaffen werden für
öffentliche trauer hieß es
in den usa ist omikron bereits die
bestimmende virusvariante und treibt die
infektionszahlen steil nach oben vor
allem in new york weil zu viele
beschäftigte ausfallen läuft die u-bahn
dort nur noch eingeschränkt zudem nehmen
die schweren krankheitsverläufe zu auch
immer mehr kinder müssen ins krankenhaus
mit einer impfpflicht für alle
arbeitnehmer will die stadt entgegen
steuern benjamin daniel hat mehr
randy leitet eine tierhandlung in queens
alle ihrer mitarbeiter haben sich
freiwillig impfen lassen nur eine hatte
sich geweigert bis jetzt denn als erste
stadt in den usa hat new york eine
impfpflicht für alle arbeitnehmer
eingeführt wenn nicht mindestens eine
dosis hat darf nicht mehr an seinen
arbeitsplatz
das verhältnis zu der mitarbeiterin war
am ende sehr angespannt im letzten
moment bevor die neue vorschrift in
kraft trat hat sich nun doch impfen
lassen aus angst ihren job zu verlieren
oder eine strafzahlung zu riskieren
es ist keine zwei jahre her dass new
york epizentrum der pandemie in den usa
war zehntausende tote leichen stapel vor
den bestattungsunternehmen bilder die
sich für immer ins gedächtnis der stadt
eingebrannt haben das dürfe sich
keinesfalls wiederholen betonte
bürgermeister mit blick auf die rekord
neue infektionszahlen besonders
besorgniserregend die
gesundheitsbehörden melden im vergleich
zur vorwoche auch viermal so viele
krankenhauseinweisungen von unter
18-jährigen die stadt stellt sich auf
einen harten winter ein
wir hatten nicht damit gerechnet dass
sich omikron so schnell ausbreiten würde
aber wir wussten es kommt dazu bei
kalten temperaturen also mussten wir
jetzt einen schritt weitergehen mit der
impfpflicht werden wir die stadt am
laufen halten nicht nur die new yorker
hoffen dass er recht behält
wie gehen andere länder mit omikron um
und was können wir daraus lernen
antworten gleich bei zdf heute live um
19 uhr 30 in unserer app in unseren
social media kanälen jeder zeit haben
wir online auch alle informationen zur
corona lage in europa und bei uns für
sie ebenfalls in unserer zdf heute
immer neue beunruhigende nachrichten
kommen aus russland jetzt sind es zwangs
untersuchungen für ausländer wer in
russland leben oder arbeiten möchte muss
künftig regelmäßig eine reihe von
medizinischen untersuchungen über sich
ergehen lassen und bezahlen blutentnahme
zum beispiel oder röntgen nicht nur die
bundesregierung sieht das kritisch aus
moskau für begannen
lebt sie will es einige der krankheiten
auf die sich alle ausländer mit
arbeitsvisum in russland ab sofort
untersuchen lassen müssen klingen
ziemlich mittelalterlich dazu hiv und
drogentests röntgenaufnahmen gespräche
mit psychologen
alexis de la roche hat das prozedere
schon einmal hinter sich gebracht der
franzose empfand es als umständlich und
erniedrigen ich würde gerne in die
gesichter russische geschäftsleute
schauen wenn sie in europa die gleichen
verfahren durchlaufen müssten hier wird
ja oft gesagt dass alle regeln auf
gegenseitigkeit beruhen sollten
russland gibt an mit dem gesetz die
volksgesundheit sichern zu wollen
betroffen sind essens kuriere und
bauarbeiter die meist aus zentralasien
kommen und städte wie moskau überhaupt
erst am laufen halten dazu fachkräfte
manager und ihre familien
damit wirkt sich das gesetz auch auf die
deutsch-russischen
wirtschaftsbeziehungen aus die bisher
gut laufen trotz der sich
verschlechternden politischen atmosphäre
die schlechte nachricht ist wenn das zur
anwendung kommt dann haben wir
sicherlich ein exodus von vielen auch
topmanagern das ist so nicht zumutbar
aber die gute nachricht ist die sache
ist deutlich entschärft laut hacker
könnten die untersuchungen
beispielsweise nur einmal statt viermal
pro jahr gefordert werden oder aber das
neue gesetz bleibt wie es ist so oder so
russland macht einen großen schritt in
richtung internationale isolation
erst gestern hatte ein urteil in
russland internationale kritik
hervorgerufen das verbot der
menschenrechtsorganisation memorial
heute ordnete ein gericht in moskau an
auch das menschenrechtszentrum von
memorial samt archiv in der hauptstadt
muss geschlossen werden memorial hatte
seit jahrzehnten die verbrechen der
kommunistischen herrschaft
aufgearbeitet und sich für politische
gefangene eingesetzt
sorge bereiten seit wochen auch
russische truppen bewegungen an der
grenze zur ukraine westliche
geheimdienste warnen vor einem möglichen
einmarsch der russen in die ukraine
moskau bestreitet das und wirft der
regierung in kiew und der nato
provokationen vor unser korrespondent
axel sturm hat im norden der ukraine an
der grenze zum belarus und russland
nachgefragt was diese bedrohung für die
menschen vor ort bedeutet bedrohung oder
nicht russische soldaten in der nähe
oder nicht natalias hühner brauchen
futter die 47-jährige sagt angst habe
sie schon vor dem krieg aber sie sagt
auch sie bleibe ich hier natürlich haben
wir angst mein sohn hat mal gefragt
mutter was machen wir wenn es krieg gibt
ich habe gesagt ich weiß auch nicht
wohin wir danken wir sind unterwegs im
dreiländereck zwischen belarus russland
und der ukraine im norden des landes
inklusive viele ältere menschen leben
eine gegend in der glaubt man den
satelliten fotos russlands präsident
putin rund 100.000 soldaten und schwere
waffen stationiert hat presseoffizier
alexej nimmt mich mit hinauf auf den
faktor 15 meter hoch blick richtung
russland
von hier aus sind es weniger als 100
meter bis nach russland wir sehen
sicherheitsinfrastrukturen sondern sie
ist weiß das kann man gut sehen
die meisten bürger hier aber wollen von
krieg nichts hören sind kriegsmüde seit
2014 schon bekämpft die ukraine die
prorussischen separatisten im osten auf
diesem weg geht es nach russland auf
diesem nach belarus und hinter mir steht
ein großes denkmal eigentlich gewidmet
der freundschaft der drei länder aber in
der ukraine rechnet man in diesen tagen
mit allem auch mit dem angriff alter
freunde wir treffen den schmied anatoli
im dorf
moskau weiß doch dass hier viele
anwohner russe stämmig sind glauben sie
wirklich sie sind dumm genug ihre
eigenen leute zu töten und doch ist sie
da die sorge darüber wie es wohl
weitergeht auch bei anatomie
die chinesische regierung ist erneut
gegen die demokratiebewegung in hongkong
vorgegangen diesmal gegen des online
magazins news polizisten durchsuchten
das redaktionsgebäude und private
wohnungen und nahmen sechs journalistin
und ehemalige mitarbeiter fest vorwurf
unter anderem verschwörung zum
veröffentlichten aufrührerischer texte
bereits im juni hatte die
pro-demokratische zeitung apple daily
ihren betrieb einstellen müssen
klimaschutzminister habeck geht davon
aus dass deutschland in den kommenden
zwei jahren seine klimaschutzziele
vermutlich verfehlen wird die neue
regierung fange mit einem drastischen
rückstand an sagte er in einem interview
mit der zeit im heute journal um viertel
vor zehn spricht claus kleber mit robert
habeck
düstere jahresbilanz des wwf die
naturschutzorganisation warnt vor einer
katastrophalen zuspitzung des weltweiten
artensterben
aktuell seien mehr als 40.000 tier und
pflanzenarten vom aussterben bedroht das
ist mehr als je zuvor so gingen die
bestände afrikanischer waldelefanten in
den vergangenen drei jahrzehnten um 86
prozent zurück auch für eisbären sehe es
wegen der erwärmung in der arktis düster
aus
lichtblick dagegen in den alpen gibt es
wieder mehr als 300 bartgeier dank eines
wiederansiedlungsprogramm
eigentlich würden ab heute auf den
verkaufstresen keine weihnachts sache
mehr liegen sondern feuerwerkskörper
eigentlich doch der verkauf von
silvesterböllern ist in deutschland
jetzt schon zum zweiten mal in folge
verboten damit will die bundesregierung
unfälle vermeiden und die überlasteten
krankenhäuser entlasten für tiere und
die umwelt ist das böllerverbot ein
segen für die branche ein desaster maike
fahrrad wieland
ein bisschen inventur aber sonst gibt es
für feuerwerker helmut reuter aus
rheinland pfalz nichts zu tun und das
zum jahreswechsel der eigentlich
arbeitsreichsten zeit das sind keine
veranstaltungen da und dann jetzt noch
silvesterfeuerwerks verkauf gestrichen
was macht dann umsatzeinbruch von circa
98 prozent was bei uns erneut darf
bundesweit kein feuerwerk an privatleute
verkauft werden damit sollen
krankenhäuser entlastet und
menschenansammlungen reduziert werden
abbrennen von altem feuerwerk ist
möglich wo das erlaubt ist entscheidet
aber jedes bundesland und jede kommune
für sich
ingo schubert vom bundesverband
pyrotechnik kann das verkaufsverbot
nicht nachvollziehen dadurch dass wir
jetzt eh versammlungsverbote haben dass
die kontakt beschränkungen zu silvester
auch aufrecht erhalten werden und man
sich nur in kleinen gruppen treffen kann
wird es ja wird es mit dem legal in
deutschland erhältlichen feuerwerk keine
schweren verletzungen geben
im lager von helmut reuter stapeln sich
so viele christen wie noch nie knapp 48
tonnen feuerwerk und darauf wird er
erneut sitzen bleiben
hierzu dir norbert und zum auftakt der
vierschanzentournee karl geier das
podest verpasst aber man muss sich noch
keine sorgen machen also umgerechnet
dreieinhalb meter rückstand ich glaube
das ist sicherlich noch aufzuholen auf
drei schanzen mit dem heimsieg in
oberstdorf hat das für karl geiger den
fünften also nicht geklappt es gewinnt
der japaner kobayashi
geigers miene nach dem sprung verrät ist
da hat nicht alles gepasst beim final
sprung als dritter nach der ko runde
muss er bei verkürztem anlauf in
strömendem regen staaten hat dann aber
plötzlich rückenwind etwas zu flach sein
sprung auf
131 meter und deshalb keine chance auf
den tagessieg heute denn sein
hauptrivale rio kobayashi fünfter nach
der ersten runde flieht mit mehr anlauf
bei besseren bedingungen ohne rückenwind
auf
141 meter siegte vor den norwegern
gerade ried und johannsen geiger wird
fünfter ja erstmal gut 1 stand also ja
mit ein bisschen geärgert aber die
abstände sind sehr eng und der erste
schritt ich mal getan sprung war nicht
so schlecht und es ist einfach ein
bisschen viel spannung heute generell
auf dem körper gewesen deshalb was
vielleicht nicht die ganz feine klinge
ein gutes team ergebnis der dsv adler
mit markus eisenbichler und stephan
leyhe auf den plätzen sieben und neun
einziger wermutstropfen ex-weltmeister
severin freund zunächst neunter wird
wegen eines nicht regelkonformen anzugs
disqualifiziert
ein tag zum vergessen für die dsv
rennläufer andreas sander als
neunzehnter der beste deutsche beim
super g in bormio es gewinnt der
norweger hilde und auch lena dürr kann
im vierten slalom der saison ihre bis
dato bestechende form nicht bestätigen
nach zwei podestplatzes platz 18 in
lienz ende stand den sieg holt sich
petra block aus der slowakei
und zweiter saison niederlage in der
premier league für jürgen klopp und den
fc liverpool zum ersten mal in dieser
spielzeit treffen die reds nicht und
verlieren bei lässt dass sie die mit 0 2
jugendclub wirkt ratlos denn seine
mannschaft zeigt derzeit nicht das was
sie eigentlich kann beispiel sein
torjäger sala nach dem foul von didi in
der 14 minute schiess der gefoulte
selbst lässt auf torhüter schmeichel
verlässt sich auf sein gefühl auch beim
zweiten versuch kein tor für liverpool
an den weiteren chancen mangelte es
nicht an ein klopps team nutzt sie nicht
der außenseiter hingegen zeigt nach dem
seitenwechsel wie es geht der
ex-leipziger ademola luckmann mit dem
einzigen treffer des abends liverpool
bleibt nach dieser niederlage sechs
zähler hinter tabellenführer manchester
city
haben können sein
okay ja und was fehlt jetzt noch wie
jeden mittwoch
sie lauten 6 10 14 20 31 46 und die
superzahl 0 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf
text auf seite 5 157
beim wetter geht es teilweise sehr mild
und nass weiter die details hat
gleichstand ali claus kleber begrüße um
15 im heute journal wir danken für ihr
interesse und wünschen ihnen noch einen
schönen armut bis morgen wenn sie merken
auch widersinnig
[Musik]
schönen abend und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter es ist viel zu mild für die
jahreszeit und das setzt sich ja auch in
den nächsten tagen fort denn es kommt
weiterhin milde luft vom atlantik zu uns
und auch wieder regen sie sehen hier die
regel bender die überqueren uns einmal
nach osten hin und erneut ist es im
nordosten deutschlands
gefährlich glatt in der nacht und regen
dort der gefriert ansonsten gibt es auch
nach süden hin regen von westen her
lockert es im laufe der nacht dann etwas
auf die temperaturen sinken bis auf
minus zwei grad in richtung nordosten
und 13 grad am niederrhein morgen im
tagesverlauf gibt es weitere regen
bender die durchziehen ja und dazwischen
auch wieder lockere auflockerungen
teilweise trocken und von westen her
neuer regen vor allem dann auch
kräftiger wind aus südwestlichen
richtungen die temperaturen dazu sieben
grad richtung ostsee und bis zu 16 grad
an den alpen gibt es tauwetter ja und
die nächsten tage gehen mit weiter an
silvester im nordwesten stürmisch aus
südwest ansonsten mit regen 9 bis 16
grad und auch danach mit ein schöner ort